[Music]
there is a plague on YouTube including
where people feel free to express their
opinion slandering their elected
officials and political leaders and we
must take this on at once these videos
will not be allowed to stand they must
be to monetize sizing sizing monetize
videos if you see something it is your
duty to create a wonderful I know your
turban to inform the authorities and
monetize we want to talk about something
right now that's a little more personal
but pretty important we wrote about it
on the website bladder with credit calm
for those who don't know and a lot of
people read it it was one of the most
shared things we wrote this week it's no
secret that Lata both credit has been
censored by facebook or been targeted
for selective oppression by Facebook
it's technically not the government so
it's not censorship but that was on
Drudge Gizmodo you know was all over the
place that ladder was Crowder was
fingered by Facebook as a page to
throttle we're fighting that legally
some ways a metaphoric middle finger yes
yeah
we're fighting that behind the scenes
okay just so you know but this week for
the first time we ran into this problem
with with Google here on YouTube and
there has been it just definitely an
uptick in election time and it's very
clear if you watch this program we're
not the people who always goes under
should have a lot of people if they just
they have something that doesn't do well
they claim they're being targeted
they're being oppressed we do it when
there's clear-cut proof a couple of
things have happened Google has blocked
or suspended lottery with credit com
from being promoted online no in any
kind of ads due to gun related imagery
and I don't know they gave another
reason I think we have an email signup
thing there so that's that hurts your
rankings that hurts if you search things
it makes you less likely to find us and
this is our livelihood but YouTube we
found out this week Jared can bring up
some some images Prager University let
us know this I did a video with them
this week they are blocking our content
through restricted mode so if you're in
restricted mode on YouTube you cannot
see our videos what does that mean that
means most public libraries that means
most schools certainly high schools a
lot of colleges most public places that
means anyone who has a youtube account
as far as I understand it under the age
of 18 YouTube doesn't allow you to see
our videos it's like a parental control
our channel follows FCC guidelines
because this show is syndicated across
the country on radio so we have to be
pretty damn careful let alone you know
it's a pg-13 at best now it is selective
because if Jerry brings up this image
again we did some comparisons if you
look at young turks every other word is
the f-word every other story is
clickbait dishonest it's attacking it's
insulting it's bullying all of their
videos are available something else if
you search steven crowder on youtube a
channel with half a million subscribers
about a hundred million plays we don't
show up that takes you to other channels
again if you are in restricted mode so
does this mean censorship no does it
mean the government is deafening is
stepping in and silencing your speech no
but it's indicative of the collusion
that's occurring with Facebook we know
Twitter we know and now YouTube
particularly in this election if you
look at the featured section on YouTube
the trending is just John Oliver Seth
Meyers Samantha P na non-stop HuffPost
video BuzzFeed and what they're doing is
clearly targeting us because we're being
effective really loud URLs Crowder's is
the most effective individual
conservative YouTube channel you got
Paul Joseph Watson does great stuff
there's some other bigger channels that
you know are parts of nonprofits or big
networks we're a lone wolf out there and
this is our livelihood so here's the
problem Google they've made many many
hundreds of thousands of dollars off of
our videos because they've monetize them
so they've chosen to court us as users
of YouTube as opposed to a different
platform by offering to pay people to
bring their content there that's what
makes YouTube and now they're changing
the deal so that's the issue they can
kick anyone they want but you can't
entice people by offering them monetary
compensation and then selectively
targeting voices of dissent so we want
you to know if you're subscribed on
YouTube just join Facebook mailing list
make sure you have some other failsafe
because every now and then people just
aren't getting our stuff and it's it's
out of our control
it's what I remember it's not fear
monger anything but it's important to
remember that these are the Liberals
that are getting voted into office these
are the same agenda that's a part of
their platform
oftentimes so I mean very very very
influential very controlling and people
that's you know it happened it's
happening in this sector in the in the
private sector first but is it's not too
far often too unrealistic to see them
pushing more of this stuff yeah and they
meet what they meet with Clinton they've
met with though they've been courted you
know Silicon Valley in the entertainment
industry is far more far more
influential than DC and that's why we
don't get as tied up about the election
because culture is always more important
and regardless of who wins you're always
gonna have the comedy central's ABC NBC
CBS Facebook Twitter YouTube that's the
real Imperial life and culture we're
also seeing a lot of universities
blocking yeah up site well that's the
restricted mode so universities
automatically website and yeah and so a
lot of people have said well why don't
you go start your own platform we always
want to fight the left where they are
okay so people are on YouTube we don't
want to go too conservative tube or to
God tube we want to get our stuff out
there because you know with that hundred
million plays we have on YouTube great
numbers were incredibly grateful they
could all go away tomorrow and we're
very aware of it but we've reached a lot
of people we've changed a lot of minds
and we don't want to shut that off that
being said it is getting to a point
where we can't be dependent on it and so
we will say this there are some things
in the works
November 8th on election night we'll be
making an announcement and if you want
to support what we do and what some
other Liberty minded conservatives do
you're going to have that opportunity
and we're not a patreon group we're not
sitting there with a cup out
warrior like a beggar what you cut back
we're not a patreon we are not going to
ask you for money whatever we do it is
going to be such a value-added
proposition that we hope you want to be
a part of it everything that's free is
always going to be free
this show is never gonna be taken off
free unless we get banned from YouTube
we'll put it on Facebook
the articles the podcasts that you get
once a week but none of that's going to
change but we are going to be adding
some things as a fail-safe here because
it is very clear that the left wants to
silence people like us we're not forcing
you to take part a lot of you have said
hey what can we buy merchandise how can
we support the program are you going
daily hashtag never daily you might want
to stay tuned for the announcement we
are going to give you the opportunity to
be more active and take a part in this
movement
because I know all of you talk about
Twitter and Facebook and you've had
pages removed and you've been banned and
you've had your colleges block our site
or to our troops thanks so much you
listen a lot of them have to only do it
through iTunes direct download because
the websites been banned and a lot of
countries or even on some military bases
and government buildings people can't
read our stuff we very much appreciate
what you go through and we understand
that a lot of you don't have the
platform we have understand that a lot
of you don't necessarily have the voice
we have we want to be a megaphone for
that and hopefully we've done that so
it's been a tough week going into
election and we are fighting these
battles on the legal front so we don't
go on social media and talk about it a
whole bunch we write about it once
typically and then work from behind the
scenes we just want you to know that you
may not be getting stuff that you're
subscribed to right now so if you
wherever you're listening iTunes right
now radio terrestrially if you're on
youtube or on the website just join
somewhere else or to other places to
make sure that you're safe and it's sad
that we have to do that and this is
emblematic of the left listen private
businesses have the right to do whatever
they want I understand that but it is
the left who is consistently at the
forefront of trying to silence voices of
hey Jerrod laughing this video is taken
from the full weekly podcast louder with
Crowder subscribe by clicking it
Jarrod's laughing because he's actually
just got shot the loss of blood is
making him delirious who shot him
guilty